Nest j/s and firebase cloud functions
both are awesome tools for node
developers and today you'll learn how to
combine the two together but first I'd
like to welcome you to a new series
called the more you code where we'll
cover highly specialized topics in about
two to three minutes and the reason I'm
creating this series is because I have a
massive list of video ideas that just
don't really fit into the 10 to
15-minute format that YouTube prefers so
rather than be a slave to the YouTube
algorithm I'm going to release some
shorter videos that hopefully you find
useful so let me know what you think
about that idea in the comments because
I'll be giving away another t-shirt with
this video and congrats to Paul boma who
is last week's winner so let's just go
ahead and get right into it
we have nest which is a nodejs framework
for building scalable server-side
applications and then we have cloud
functions which is the actual
infrastructure that allows a server-side
application to scale infinitely sounds
like a pretty good match if you ask me
so let's look at two different ways we
can combine these two technologies
together friends who were majestic
translucent seeds shooting flaming
arrows I would follow you into the Mists
of Avalon that's me
the first option will look at starts
with a nest application and then brings
in cloud functions the second option
will do the exact opposite start with a
functions project and then bring in nest
so this first option is ideal if you
have an existing nest app that you want
to deploy cloud functions so we'll go
ahead and generate a new nest
application then from the parent
directory we'll go ahead and initialize
firebase functions we don't actually
want the functions directory so just go
ahead and delete it now by default the
firebase functions environment will be
looking for the functions directory so
we'll want to go into the firebase JSON
and change the source to server or
whatever the name of your nest
application is and then we'll want to
install the dependencies that we would
normally use in the functions
environment like firebase functions
admin Express and then also nest Jas
platform Express now when cloud
functions attempts to run your code it
will be looking for the main field in
the package.json and we'll set that up
as the dist index.js file and then
you'll also want to set the node engine
to 8 or 10 or whatever version you want
to use from there we need to create the
actual server and we'll do that inside
the source directory in this index TS
file and this file will create an
instance of an express app and then
we'll write a function called create
nest server and it's
sponsibility is to wrap that Express app
with our app module and nest then we'll
go ahead and call this function and it
returns a promise so we'll want to make
sure to handle it with then and catch
and then the last step is just to export
the cloud function which will go ahead
and call API and it's just a firebase
HTTP function that takes the Express app
as its argument and that's all there is
to it we can now compile the server with
NPM run build that will generate the
dist folder and then we can run firebase
serve only functions to serve the
functions locally or deploy them with
firebase deploy only functions then you
should be able to make a request to that
URL and get a response from the nest
application now one thing that I'll
mention is that this whole process could
be made a lot easier if someone
developed a schematic for this not that
these setup is all that hard but as your
functions already have a schematic that
allow you to handle all the setup with a
single command and that makes me kind of
jealous as someone who primarily uses
GCP but let's go ahead and move on to
the second setup strategy you may have
an existing firebase project that
already has its own background functions
and you want to add nest to that project
for your HTTP functions in that case you
would go into the functions directory
and manually install the nest
dependencies and then you'd likely want
to create a nest CLI JSON file in the
functions directory to use the nest CLI
to automatically generate your code and
as you can see here I can now call nest
generate for an app module and a
controller but at this point we'll get
some errors because the cloud functions
environment doesn't have things like
decorators and able by default we can
fix that by going to the TS config and
then we'll add the options that would
normally be present in a nest app from
there we'll go into the index TS file
and write these same exact code that we
wrote in the previous example and now we
can run npm run serve to serve the
functions locally or firebase deploy
only functions to deploy them and that
gives you another option to set up an
sas with cloud functions become best
friends yep I'm gonna go ahead and wrap
things up there but you can expect more
nest content in the near future if this
video helped you please like and
subscribe and consider becoming a pro
member at fire ship IO thanks for
watching and I will talk to you soon
[Music]